We are now considering the
motion of a rigid body.
And we'd like to talk about
kinetic energy of rotation
and properties of
that rigid body.
Let's consider a
rigid body, and let's
say that our rigid body is
rotating about an axis passing
through a point S.
If we look overhead
at our rigid body,
then what we're going to do is
introduce a coordinate system.
So this is our overhead view.
And suppose that we have a
small element of our rigid body
here, which I'm going
to write as delta m j.
And that's a distance
r j from the center.
Our rigid body has
an angle theta.
And what we'd like to do is
describe a coordinate system,
r hat, theta hat, and k
hat pointing like that.
Now, with this rigid
body that's rotating,
we describe the angular
velocity as the rate
that the angle is changing
with respect to k hat.
And so we can draw
the vector omega,
and this establishes
our coordinate system
for our rigid body and a small
element of mass, delta m j.
Now, what we'd
like to consider is
what does this mass element do?
Imagine that it's over there.
Because every point
in the rigid body
has the same angular
velocity, this object
is going in a circle with
angular velocity omega.
Recall that omega is
perpendicular to the plane
of motion.
But the object itself
has a velocity,
which I'm going to write v j.
And that velocity vector, v j,
is in the tangential direction.
And it's related to the z
component of our angular
velocity by the
following relationship--
it's how far we are
from the center point,
S, times the z component
of the angular velocity.
And it's pointing in the
tangential direction.
So remember that omega z
is equal to d theta dt.
And this describes
our coordinate system
for the rigid body.
Now what we'd like to discuss
is the kinetic energy.
And the way we're going
to consider kinetic energy
is, we're going to sum up
the rotational kinetic energy
of every single mass element.
So we begin by writing
k j rotational.
And we know that that is just
1/2 times the mass element
times the velocity of
that element squared.
Now we can use our relationship
for the tangential velocity
element related to
the angular velocity.
And we have 1/2 delta m j r j
squared times omega z squared.
Now keep in mind that omega z is
the same for every single mass
element, but the distance
of the mass elements
are all different by r j.
So the total rotational
kinetic energy
is the sum over j
from 1 to n of, let's
put the 1/2 outside, times
delta m j r j squared.
Now again, recall that every
element has the same omega z.
So I can write parentheses
omega z squared.
And that's our rotational
kinetic energy.
So what we want to do
now is look at the limit
as our delta m j becomes
very small, because we
have a continuous body.
And we'll write a
definition, which
is going to be the
moment of inertia passing
through this point, S, about
the axis passing through S
is equal to the limit
as delta m j goes to 0
or n goes to infinity of this
sum-- delta m j r j squared,
j goes from 1 to n.
Now because this is a limit
for the continuous body,
we'll define it as the
integral over the body
of a small mass element dm.
That's a distance r squared.
Now here, what is
the meaning of the r?
For our continuous body
here, if we call this dm
and we define the distance
from S to the body r-- and now
I'm going to just put a
little notation in here.
It's the distance from S, the
axis we're calculating about,
to where the body is dm.
So I'll write S dm.
This is what we call
the moment of inertia
of a continuous body.
Now again, what's very
important to realize--
it's a moment about
a particular axis.
So this is about an axis
passing perpendicular
to the plane of rotation
and through S, point S.
So it's an axis that's
passing perpendicular
to the plane of rotation
passing through the point S.
And this is what we call the
moment of inertia of a body.
Now, we'll see that the moment
can be expressed in terms
of other physical quantities.
As the course
develops, you'll see
two or three more
fundamental relations
for moment of inertia.
But what we'd like to do now
is summarize our results--
that the kinetic energy of
rotation is 1/2 for rotation
about this axis, I'm just to
indicate passing through S,
of I s times omega z squared.
Now keep in mind, because
omega z is a component,
it can be positive,
0, or negative.
But the square is always a
positive definite quantity.
And that's our kinetic
energy of rotation.
Let's contrast that with our
translational kinetic energy.
And we remember there that
was 1/2 times the total mass
of the object
times v squared cm,
where we're looking
at all of the objects
at the center of mass.
And this is the total
mass of the object.